la perte d'un enfant d'une étude est une
souffrance le fait que l'offre coupable
et l'autre soit soit une victime
innocente ne change rien à cette douleur
là
[Musique]
je suis le père de samia me moore l'un
des trois assaillants du bataclan
pourquoi à bien tout simplement parce
que je cherche pas à être médiatisé puis
bon c'est j'ai pas envie de prendre de
risque et m'exposer je suis le père de
aulas qui est morte assassinée au
bataclan le 13 novembre 2015
je ne sais pas si la balle qui a tué
lola est sorti de larmes de samy ou de
celle d'un de ses deux complices mais
pour moi ça me fait ça ne fait aucune
différence
[Rires]
le plus difficile pour moi c'était au
départ
d'accepter de rencontrer deux rencontres
résine parce que à titre personnel ça
remet pas mal d'émotion en tant que
président de l'association des victimes
ça pouvait être un geste qui risquait
d'être éventuellement mal compris pour
moi c'était une thérapie et c'était
vraiment j'ai essayé de comprendre y
avait certaines choses que vraiment
cliqué kim inciter à aller au delà et
puis et puis dialoguer essayer de
trouver des réponses pour moi ça c'est
certainement quelque chose qui m'aide
mais ça se situe dans l'ensemble de tout
ce que j'ai fait depuis le 13ème en 2015
qui a été de moreau m 2 nous essayons
d'agir asie namur n'est pas né par le
coupable n'est pas amené pas
responsables des crimes qui ont été
commis
[Musique]
je me considère comme une victime parce
que parce que
et même je considère que mon fils est
une victime aussi parce que vraiment
j'ai tout fait j'ai tout fait pour le
sortir de de cette voie là et puis bon
je n'ai pas réussi mais
je ne sais pas où j'ai failli je suis
toujours à leur recherche
j'arrive pas à réaliser je suis toujours
je continue à culpabiliser quelque part
voilà je comprends pas les parents de
djihadistes
ont perdu ont perdu un enfant le fait
qu'ils aient commis des actes souvent
parfois terribles comme dans le cas des
tas de samy est un cas extrême mais
d'autres comme dit également des
attentats-suicide en syrie où des choses
comme ça n'enlève rien au fait que les
parents et mes leurs enfants gardent le
souvenir de l'enfant quand il avait 12
ans quand elle quand il avait 15 ans
[Musique]
un sami pourquoi cette question occupe
depuis le 13 novembre pourquoi toi et
tes complices avaient commis ces crimes
atroces
vous avez volé leur vie à des jeunes de
votre âge que vous ne connaissiez pas
vous avez perdu la vôtre dans la sphère
vous avez plongé dans un cauchemar les
parents les amis de ceux que vous avez
tué et votre également vous avez laissé
des blessures indélébiles à ceux qui ont
survécu à vos tirs vous avez sali votre
religion
aux yeux du monde vous avez mis en
danger tous les musulmans dont certains
ont payé de leur vie dans des épisodes
abominable de vengeance aveugle et tout
cela pourquoi l'eau la chaire lola très
cher lula j'aurais aimé ne pas avoir à
écrire cette lettre
après cette longue conversation avec ton
père je découvre que nous avions bien
des choses en commun la musique le sport
les voyages l'egypte
je sais le vide que tu laisses autour de
toi pour tes amis et surtout pour tes
parents mon coeur de perles c'est tu es
parti trop tôt ta vie tu as été arrachée
par une idéologie meurtrière
ceux qui ont commis ces horaires n'ont
pas servi d'islam
bien au contraire règle au soulier je me
demande pourquoi sans arriver à trouver
de réponse mais je faillis à mon rôle de
père moi qui croyait donner une bonne
éducation à mon fils pardon mille fois
lola